on se retrouve avec cette fois deux
candidates les deux finalistes de la
première circonscription de haute saône
celle de vesoul gré l'ouest du
département
donc les résultats de dimanche ils vont
s'afficher tout de suite
barbara beso ballot la candidate de la
république en marche vire en tête avec
28,6 pour cent des suffrages devant la
frontiste léonie cugnaux 19,3 les deux
candidats du parti les républicains vous
le voyez marie breton et dimitri doussot
sont éliminées bonjour à toutes les deux
barbara beso vélo on commence avec vous
vous avez bénéficié comme votre
adversaire de la division des candidats
de droite qui totalise quasiment 30% des
suffrages
à eux deux qu'avez vous à dire à leur
électorat pour les convaincre de se
porter sur votre candidature dimanche
prochain vous savez dans notre
circonscription c'est c'est un moment
dur c'est très dur ce que je rencontre
genre je vois des gens paix n'est fâché
de cette division
donc cet électorat je le redis je
comprends leur leur colère leur compte
je comprends que tous leurs espoirs a
été anéantie dès le premier tour parce
que quand on voudrait quand on est dans
un groupe on croit toujours qu'on est
les meilleurs et qu'on a eu une très
bonne idée
maintenant n'ayons pas peur de l'avenir
avançons ensemble et rassemblons nous
vous avait annoncé avant le premier tour
que vous étiez de sensibilité centre
gauche
icap est ce un handicap c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je stéphane pini mon
suppléant dont je suis très fier élu à
la ville de vesoul est plutôt de
centre-droit il est directeur d'un
collège moi je suis plutôt dans le privé
directrice de l'entreprise donc on a
souhaité justement c'est cette alliance
si on peut appeler ça comme ça c'est
pour pouvoir montrer aux gens
effectivement qu'on peut arriver de
différents horizons et avoir parlé du
projet de l'avenir les audi cugnaux
cette circonscription était donc un fief
de la droite parlementaire pierre
chantelat christian berger l'un alain
joyandet alain chrétien
comment convaincre l'électorat de droite
traditionnelle de voter pour vous
dimanche prochain
écoutez moi mon but ce n'est pas de
convaincre uniquement l'électorat de
droite traditionnel dimanche prochain
mais plutôt de de provoquer un grand
rassemblement derrière - candidature de
toutes les personnes qui ont envie
d'avoir une france libre et souveraine
parce que je rappelle qu'un député de la
nation doit défendre les intérêts du
peuple français et donc j'en appelle à
tous ceux qui aiment la france et qui
ont envie d'avoir une réelle opposition
une réelle force d'opposition de
propositions à l'assemblée nationale de
me soutenir
alors néanmoins marine le pen était
arrivée largement très largement en tête
du premier tour de la présidentielle
en sept semaines seulement vous faites
10 points de moins vous avez perdu 55 %
des suffrages
vous vivez ça comme un désaveu personnel
ah non pas du tout non je comment vous
l'expliquez cette fuite des électeurs de
marine le pen
alors tout d'abord il n'y a pas eu
seulement une fuite des électeurs de
marine le pen puisque au niveau national
nous avons perdu 500 mille voix ou c par
rapport aux dernières élections
législatives de 2012
je rappelle quand même que les
républicains n'ont perdu trois millions
et demi est le parti socialiste 6
millions donc je pense que la vague ma
chronique ne nous a pas submerger comme
certains peuvent le penser
après je pense aussi qu'il faut
comprendre que les gens puissent avoir
envie de se détourner du vote parce que
ça fait des mois et des mois qu'ils
entendent parler politique et qui n'ont
pas forcément l'impression qu'on l'ait
qu'on les écoute et qu'on les comprend
mais après voilà moi j'ai envie de leur
montrer que on a une belle
circonscription et ce n'est pas en
allant voter pour une énième députés
macro nist que ça va donner de l'écho à
notre territoire mais plutôt en se
portant sur ma candidature il justement
ils trouveront une voix à l'assemblée
nationale qui sera beaucoup plus
entendue écoutée et qui représenterait
une réelle opposition
alors vous êtes toutes les deux novices
ni l'une ni l'autre n'ont exercé de
mandat local jusqu'à présent quels
éléments de votre parcours personnel
professionnel à toutes les deux vous
souhaitez mettre en avant pour pour
convaincre les électeurs que vous ferez
une bonne député de haute saône madame
vaisseau ballot je voudrais juste
revenir sur la partie 2 qui vient d'être
dit il ya quand même la moitié sur 88
mille électeurs dans notre
circonscription il y en a la moitié qui
ne sont pas venus voter qui ne se sont
pas exprimés donc ça prouve bien déjà
qu' il ya des bouts il ya la moitié des
électeurs qui n'ont même plus d'espoir
par rapport à la politique donc falloir
retrouver cette partie là maintenant
parlons de ceux qui se sont déplacés et
qui ont dit en tout cas qu'ils ne
voulaient plus de la politique comme il
se faisait en tout cas justement vous
êtes deux novices c'est la question que
vous qu'est ce que veut dire novice en
politique politique c'est savoir gérer
les sites est d'accord est ce que une
maman de trois enfants donc mère de
famille chef d'entreprise femmes de
mères épouses de mer donc ayant le 6 le
respect de l'engagement
vous êtes l'épousé du maire de marne est
depuis 2001 effectivement j'ai un
profond respect pour les personnes qui
se sont engagées qui s'engagent en
politique
qu'avez vous à répondre à léonie cugnaux
aviez dit que vous serez une député
godillot parmi tous les autres députés
je pense qu'un situation de la france
est assez grave pour voir qu'il faut
avance avancer rapidement
je crois que les gens qui ont voté
emmanuel macron pour l'étiquette
nationale et j'espère qu'on a quand même
quelques-uns qui ont voté pour moi parce
qu on a fait vraiment un très fort
travail
donc ces personnes là en tout cas où
envie que ça avance vite il quand ils
viennent dans les urnes alors qu'un à la
moitié qu'il ne vienne pas ceux qui
viennent en tout cas disent oui on veut
que vous avons skié vite
dépêchons-nous parce que la situation
est grave léonie cugnaux même question
quels éléments quels éléments de votre
parcours professionnel vous êtes
étudiante aussi assistante de groupes au
front national à la région en quoi cela
peut constituer des atouts pour devenir
député
écoutez c'est sûr qu'en étant étudiante
en droit ça me donne déjà beaucoup de
connaissances juridiques qui vont me
permettre d'avoir d'avoir quand même des
connaissances plus que je pense ma
concurrente
donc c'est un atout le fait d'avoir été
c'est sûr depuis le mois de septembre
une collaboratrice pour le groupe à la
région également puisque j'ai pu grâce à
sophie montel qui m'a accordé sa
confiance
découvrir de plus près le monde
politique le travail au conseil régional
donc c'est un c'est un second atout et
puis je suis quand même issu des petites
classes moyennes donc je comprends les
problème je comprends j'entends la
douleur des gens la souffrance que ça
soit la souffrance des retraités qui
vont d'ailleurs être touchés par la
hausse de la csg pour 60% d'entre eux je
comprends qu'il y ait également des
problèmes d'emploi puisque je suis jeune
et que en cela je m'inquiète également
pour mon avenir
est-ce que j'ai des perspectives
d'avenir est ce que je vais pouvoir
trouver facilement un emploi et je ne
pense pas non plus que la loi travail
puisse faire la loi elle comrie
puissance 10 va permettre de donner des
belles perspectives d'avenir à la
jeunesse et à tout le monde en général
donc en cela je pense que je suis la
plus à même à représenter mes
concitoyens regardez ce que vous êtes
inquiète comme tout le monde comme moi
je suis inquiète
qu'est ce que ça va servir que vous
alliez à l'assemblée nationale pour vous
opposer à quoi il faut avancer contre
nous si j'étais des années contre
maintenant on en est au moment où il
faut être pour
il faut avancer allons dans les projets
qu'est ce qu'un mode n importe quel
projet présenté par le modèle de solow
parce que c'est là que vous manquez fait
on sait réellement qu emmanuel macron
est là pour proposer n'importe quoi je
ne le crois n'importe quoi je dis
n'importe quel texte
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose eh
bien je pense qu'il ne va pas proposer
n'importe quel texte est effectivement
dans nos groupes de travail nous serons
là pour veiller dans nos
circonscriptions il y avait
effectivement un élément qui inquiète
tout le monde sait la ruralité
nous créerons sans doute un groupe pour
la ruralité pour voir les emmanuel
macron a dit d'ailleurs chaque commune
est un territoire
donc j'ai confiance quand j'entends ça
léonie du lion non mais écoutez je pense
qu'on n'a pas du tout la même vision des
choses moi je vois un chaos social en
perspective pour le moment c'est un
petit moment de flottement mais je pense
qu'on va vite rentrer dans le dur vous
voyez vous et donc je pense comme je
disais que la loi notamment la loi elle
comme rive à précariser les plus faibles
et donc je vois pas bien l'intérêt
peut-être pour cette loi parce que c'est
simple vous allez arriver à l'assemblée
nationale vous allez votez votez votez
votez votez tout tout tout sera bientôt
3% sans même faire de proposition de loi
puisque finalement vous serez pas du
tout une force de proposition à moins
qu'on vous dicte les propositions à
faire mais qui de toute façon et
viendront directement des manuels mâcon
donc je vois pas l'intérêt
et moi je pense madame que les près de
11 millions de français qui ont voté
pour le front national ont envie d'être
représentés manuel et vous aurez et de
toute façon emmanuel macron a déjà
largement sa majorité donc un de plus ou
un de moins ça va pas changer
grand-chose caisse pourquoi êtes vous
vous êtes pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes
contre vous nous le dit depuis le début
vous êtes contre maintenant qu'est-ce
que vous allez défendre mais je suis
contre la politique qui va être mené par
emmanuel macron d'accord ça on est bien
on a bien entendu maintenant pour quelle
politique et pour quelle politique et
vous qu'est-ce que vous avez défendre
par rapport à la circonscription qui va
faire avancer la circonscription ou même
notre niveau notre politique
oui alors tout d'abord on va mettre les
points sur les i sur quelque chose
visiblement vous n'avez pas compris ce
que c'était qu'un député puisse qu'un
député et député de la nation
vous voyez c'est un c'est un mandat
national dont quand cela sert consonnes
élu dans une circonscription mais nous
allons voter des lois nationales
tout a donc mon rôle sera bien sûr de
représenter la circonscription dans ces
problématiques qui d'ailleurs représente
également les problématiques nationales
que ce soit la ruralité
au niveau des des agriculteurs qui ont
des difficultés que ça soit les
retraites et que ce soit les jeunes que
ça soit voilà les petites classes
moyennes et qu'il agrippe en difficulté
qui sont trop pauvres
pourquoi on leur accorde des aides mais
aussi trop riche pour en avoir ou
également donc voyez ces gens là sont
dans la souffrance
les ce n'est pas en ayant une énième
député macro nist qu'ils vont avoir
l'impression de pouvoir exprimer leur
voix à travers vous mais pas du tout je
vous laisse répondre madame b ce mot là
qu'est ce que vous voulez que je réponde
par rapport à je demande pour quel sujet
allez vous allez vous défendre et on me
répond part je pense que vous ne
défendrait pas mieux la partie macro n'y
n est qu une question très précise à
trépas de il ya eu une actualité
cette semaine dans votre circonscription
qui n'est pas anodine c'est la
manifestation des agriculteurs qui
estime qu'il faut revaloriser d'urgence
le prix du lait pour qu'ils puissent
vivre tout simplement de leur travail un
combat que vous comptez mener à
l'assemblée sur quelles priorités
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue à
toutes les deux
sur ce dossier la léonie cugnaux bien
sûr tout à fait les agriculteurs sont
dans une détresse tels que vous n'étiez
pas à la réunion qui était justement
laquelle vous étiez à ce que nous ici à
celle de la coordination rurale
non mais puisque je faisais encore vous
allez nous jour dans les grosses
structures voyez vous on nous parle
pneus m'attaquez pas là dessus c'est
bien inutile puisque j'ai rencontré
autant d'agriculteurs que vous et la
coordination rurale a encore encore
attend votre réponse à son invitation
la partie risque que nous demande sur la
question rémy chevreuils sont
alsaciennes et puis un stage en effet
s'assurer des agriculteurs il est un
réel problème là dessus et je pense je
vois pas comment vous comptez les
défendre parce que c'est bien beau quand
elle est belle et si l'ambulance de
rencontrer les gens d'aller faire voilà
de te prôner la proximité mais au final
vous allez faire qu'appliquer un
programme national madame et sur quoi
vous basez que j'ai fait semblant
sur quoi vous basez parce que ça n'a
aucun intérêt ce que vous faites vous
allez vente et que vous allez défendre
la ruralité en vérité non puisque vous à
les appliquer
sur la partie 2
l'agriculture l'agriculture
effectivement je suis aller les écouter
il était dans un moment fort en plus les
résultats du premier tour et est tombé
et c'était un moment difficile pour eux
j'ai essayé d'être le plus loyal de
d'écouter ce qu'ils avaient à dire
j'ai rencontré d'autres agriculteurs que
cette fédération là il faut se battre en
priorité pour que les agriculteurs
puissent vivre dignement de leur travail
je crois que c'est le sujet numéro un
qui les inquiète on arrive au terme de
ce troisième débat léonie cugnaux votre
conclusion vous avez trente secondes
pour convaincre les électeurs de voter
pour vous dimanche
écoutez moi ce que je vais dire aux
électeurs de la première circonscription
des hauts-de-seine s'est d'abord merci
merci de m'avoir permis d'accéder à ce
second tour
je suis fier et c'est un honneur pour
moi de vous représenter ce que je veux
moi c'est représenter une réelle
opposition
voilà je veux fédérer tous ceux qui
veulent s'opposer à la politique macro
tous ceux qui aiment la france et croyez
moi je porterais votre voix à
l'assemblée nationale merci léonie
cugnaux barbara baisse au balo votre
conclusion
alors effectivement merci aussi à mes
électeurs qui m'ont accordé largement
leur soutien lors de ce premier tour
je veux simplement leur dire
n'ayons pas peur qu'est ce qu'on risque
à part de réussir on risque simplement
de rester comme on est aujourd'hui on
sait que ce n'est plus possible
donc je propose rassemblement pour
avancer pour être pour pour des nouveaux
projets pour que la haute saône fois
plus grande
demain merci à toutes les deux pour ce
débat tout de suite un nouveau face à
face
[Musique]